Biden lists hundreds of social media
influencers for upcoming re-election bid
of course Joe Biden is enlisting help of
hundreds of social media influencers in
this unannounced re-election bid with an
emphasis on mobilizing young voters
according to Newport influences will be
cross-platforms such as Tick Tock
Instagram and Twitter will praise
Biden's accomplishments and agenda to
their followers the influencers are not
getting paid and there are four digital
staffers devoted to working with them
who are officially employees of the
White House some of the enlisted
influencers include 20 year old Tick
Tock Creator Harry Sisson Boston college
professor and Twitter users Heather Cox
Richardson and financial tick tocker
Vivian too what do you think about this
oh God you know who doesn't want uh Tick
Tock to be banned nationally the Biden
Administration obviously when you read
that story and you think to yourself
okay are they going to ban Tick Tock uh
probably not given that we've got the
2024 election coming up and you know I I
give the Democrats credit because they
are much better at messaging they're
much better at understanding the
Dynamics of communicating right and the
Republicans you know they couldn't
organize panic in a Dube submarine right
I mean they're really they need to to
pay attention to what the dams are doing
because they they are effective you can
agree or disagree with how they go about
it and frankly the other point then I'll
shut up is it is that bite dance in
China
completely different animal yeah right
there is no way in hell that 99 of the
crap on Tick Tock would ever make its
way on the bite dance they won't allow
it right and there's a reason for that
is because they look at it and go this
shit's degenerative so anyway that's no
I agree with you so I'm like what do you
think and going off Adam's Point what do
you think hey obviously biting them like
it because of the reach that it gets to
these young people but what is what is
China because I don't trust China at all
I don't give a sh every time I talk
people like oh you're racist no I'm not
racist against the Chinese I'm I hate
the Chinese government how they treat
their people do you think that China is
just trying to make our youth soft just
in case I'm just going for for
militarily if you have to attack or
whatever as long as the men are soft you
can take over or like a revolution from
yeah sure I think absolutely they look
at they look at this as a as a as a
essentially a a cold war on many
different fronts right so they're out
there hoovering up economic information
right they're Gathering all they've been
doing that for decades very aggressively
and they're busy building up their
military and they're also understanding
the impact of technology and they've
been looking at this I mean it's the
same thing that's Russian disinformation
whatever it may be it's the same thing
the Chinese just have more the regime
has more resources yeah I agree with you
I I it drives me crazy when people go
well look at you you know I choose
xenophobic yeah you know no I'm talking
look at Chinese culture history people
amazing right it's an incredible place
the regime
sucks right she has cemented himself as
president for life he is he has put his
thumb down their internal security
service is stronger than it's ever been
there's no rule of law right and and
it's all thanks to XI and his and his
cronies look they believe that they are
as close as they've ever been to the top
step of the of the ladder on the food
chain right they are and they are
convinced that they're almost there and
they're acting like it one more point
the uh you brought up uh basically what
they show on tick tock
in the United States which has already
been banned by many government officials
India I think has banned and some other
companies have banned it is wildly
different of what they showed the youth
in China by the way Vinnie do you know
what they show the youth in China on
American social media apps like uh
Instagram YouTube Facebook Snapchat do
you know what they should in China yeah
from art no yeah nothing because that's
not allowed in their country okay they
don't allow any of the our American
owned apps in their country well they do
they do show the Bud Light commercials
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]